10.400 20 verschiedenen arten alles klar
der herzlichkeit sondern wie leute ich
glaube wir mit einem neuen video zurück
für euch weil ich letztens auf youtube
unterwegs war und dann habe ich so ein
video am rande vorgeschlagen gesehen um
einen platz gedacht hier klar sebastian
dass er wieder irgendeinen unsinn von
hilft mir braucht sich gar nicht um
beschäftigen dann habe ich mir den kanal
angeschaut auf dem es hochgeladen wurde
und schon wieder muss ich gestehen ich
wünschte es wäre hilft mir aber es ist
kein helfen das video anschauen werden
leute da geht es um eine frau die
ernsthaft süchtig nach nagellack ist ich
dachte aber wusste bis dato nicht dass
das möglich ist schaut man kann man
süchtig nach nagellack sein
wie gesagt noch mal der stelle es ist
kein hilfe ja kein scherz okay okay da
musst du dir stoppen ich google jetzt
mal weil ich als man natürlich keine
ahnung davon haben wie viel wie sie
kostet so ein nagellack also sehr 10.000
verschiedene nagellacke ich werde mal so
zuerst besten stationen gegangen die ich
mir jetzt ausruhen konnte sich einfach
dm und so die dm ein stop ich dir im
eigenmarke ja oder so kostet 8 euro wenn
ich das mal ausrechnen sieht das ganze
nicht gut aus selbst wenn ihre nagellack
waschen im durchschnitt fünf euro
gekostet haben was glaube ich schon
wenig ist für nagellack oder reden hier
über 50.000 euro in nagellack betritt
man die wohnung von carolin gehören
hamburger norden kann man sie nicht
übersehen die
der flur oder schlafzimmer und
wohnzimmer alles ich bin wirklich
gespannt auf die erklärung wie sie
erzählt wie sie zu dieser die situation
reingekommen ist also ich will erstmal
habe ich deutschen leute wie gesagt die
menschen sehr offen und erstmal
unvoreingenommen aber ich bin sehr sehr
sehr sehr gespannt was ihre erklärung
dafür ist oder zumindest wenn sie jetzt
keine erklärung hat was sie sich im
nachhinein so zusammenbleibt warum das
passiert das ganz schön teuer pro monat
oder 150 200 geht schon ein bisschen
geld drauf
aber ganz ehrlich die die burg mega
sympathisch also die logik finde ich
jetzt auch nicht verkehrt also ich meine
ich habe ja selbst wenn mal geraucht
gott sei dank nicht mehr und so wenn man
keine ahnung also fertiges haus aus
packung er gut 250 euro wären immer noch
20 packungen im monat es ist ja aber das
mit das kriegen wir hin glaube ich also
man muss jetzt so gut erhalten immerhin
schaltet sich ihre eigene gesundheit
damit er hat sich natürlich recht und
jetzt bitte festhalten
es gibt sogar ein eigenes nagellack
zimmer karan lebt in einen nagellack
traum vom auftritt über die tasche bis
zur lampe auch persönlich sagen ich für
die machten sehr glücklichen eindruck
also die macht jetzt nicht den eindruck
also ich dachte vorher also dieses video
gesehen habe dachte ich dass da jetzt
wieder eine person kommt so wie es auch
bei den ich will eine barbie sein videos
ist wo man sich wirklich denkt kann
bitte jemand diesen menschen in den arm
nehmen und ihm helfen dem geht es nicht
gut aber ganz ehrlich die wird gechillt
hat sogar ein oberteil an wunden
nagellack drauf steht auf englisch so
erwert auch nicht nötig gewesen
also ganz ehrlich inter dir stehen 81
millionen flaschen verstehen warum also
welche vorgaben
ich habe dazu eine sehr guten kommentare
von elvis xo ich meine alle schreiben
dieses gestört memi aber selbst 200 euro
im monat für markenklamotten ausgehen
denkt mal drüber nach macht an sich sind
also ich meine ich kenne auch leute die
geben 400 euro für ein t-shirt auswahl
der valencianer darauf darf man sich
auch fragen ob das jetzt sinnvoll ist
sieht ihr freund das genauso fabrizio
die sind seit 17 jahren ein paar mal
ehrlich welcher mann zieht denn
freiwillig ins nagellack wunderland ein
sie hatte sogar ernsthaft über ihrer tür
stehen ist er ist dass die wohnungstür
also diese bisschen groß aus person
nebenzimmer oder also dieses nagellack
zimmer satz aus dem nebenzimmer das
sieht aus wie die wohnungstüre gehabt
dass feiert ja irgendwie aus also die
art und weise wie sie das überbrückt das
ist mega sympathisch und das ist
vielleicht ist es auch ein bisschen
selbstironisch von ihr sind sie denkt
sich so ja okay ich übertreibe stadt ein
bisschen so 81 trillionen nagellack
fläschchen zu hause dann kann ich die
wohnung auch nagellack wunderland nennen
wir hat das ganz clever gemacht hat
begonnen mit ganz wenige nagellacke er
hatte wahrscheinlich 100 200 stück heute
bin ich bis dato an der realität vorbei
gegangen was nagellack angeht sind 100
stück oder 200 stück wenig drücke ich
habe in den kommentaren nach
informationen gesucht und laura herr
schreibt sie hat begonnen mit ganz wenig
nagellacke 100 200 stück alles klar dass
miley ich habe um die 80 und finde das
schon viel
die 80 andere schreiben so ich hab nicht
mal 20 ich hab ich mir wirklich keine
ahnung davon aber allein 20 verschiedene
nagellacke und einen kleinen preis
versteckt plätze kamen regale überall
sie geht so ganz kurz brot kaufen und
kommen sie zurück mit zwei brötchen und
30 mal gesagt ich fahre diese frau die
die hier wirklich die macht eigentlich
die macht im smartphone- coolen eindruck
auf mich
das ist nämlich auch einer der
entscheidenden punkte bei solchen sachen
wenn man sich die leute anschaut und hat
das gefühl die sind geistig nicht ganz
auf der höhe
betrachtet man das ganze gleich mal ein
bisschen mehr negativ war habe ich
diesen job nicht die wirkt als wir
sieben vollbesitz ihrer sinne und ihrer
geistigen kräfte und hat einfach bock
auf nagellack sehr viel bock 34 350 lage
ihre babys hat mittlerweile den wert
eines kleinwagens und sie kommen aus der
ganzen welt zum beispiel aus tunesien
afghanistan und korea in kleinwagen also
noch mal leute ich weiß ich habe nicht
so viel ahnung davon kennen sie nur ganz
ganz simple hochrechnung machen sind
fünf euro durchschnittlich für nagellack
zu viel gut wenn sie auch im ausland
kauften chinesen sind wahrscheinlich mal
günstig aber teure dabei also müsst ihr
mal eine kommentare schreiben aber ich
komme bei 10.000 nagellacken und keine
ahnung sagen wir vier euro immer noch
40.000 euro das leisten manche leute als
anzahlung von sehr schönes haus
mitgebracht von freunden und bekannten
den teuersten lack hat caro den sich
allerdings selbst gekauft für 150 euro
einen nagellack
das beseitigt uralter also werden sie
jetzt noch ein paar von denen hat gut
ich meine jetzt der bild schon besonders
hervorgehoben reisekosten wahrscheinlich
nicht so viele in der größenordnung aber
wenn sie nur ein paar hat die in die
richtung gehen dann zieht es den ganzen
durchschnitt immer nach oben also ich
will einerseits will ich wissen
andererseits will ich auch nicht wissen
wieviele euro sei ein nagellack versenkt
worden wobei dann andererseits hat so
100 bis 200 euro pro monat für ein
mensch der arbeitet es halt auch nicht
viel so also seid ja jemand der zu 35
ist mitten im leben steht mitten im
leben gerettet ich war jahrelang in der
gastronomie gott hat eigentlich immer
die farbe tragen die ich wollte hatte
zwischendurch mal einen job und durfte
kein nagellack tragen
seht ihr gesichtsausdruck sofort
gewünscht dass gerade immer so her so
dieses sympathische lächeln was ja die
ganze zeit drauf hatte was so jemand hat
der weiß dass er gerade irgendwie so ein
bisschen freaky schiff macht aber
andererseits auch dazu steht uns auch
feierte und jetzt ist so wahrscheinlich
das schwierigste tiefpunkte in ihrem
leben einen job bei dem man kanal
nachfragen darf ak folter aber ihren
frau alter also von riehl vorrätig habe
schlimmere sachen erwartet bei diesem
video
wobei ich will jetzt auch die die
stimmung nicht dämpfen aber ich hab' ich
sehe hier eine akute bedrohung und zwar
ich fühle mich an der stelle
verpflichtet an caroline so ist die frau
aus diesem kleinen club eine botschaft
zu senden und zwar caroline du bist in
akuter gefahr ich habe soeben
ausgerechnet 10.000 nagellack hast du da
wenn man davon ausgeht dass du mit jedem
neuen flächen drei mal deine nägel
machen kannst kamera bestimmt oder so
willig rad einfach dann hat carolin
leute und haltet euch bitte fest nur
noch 82 zwei jahre vorrat an nagellack
in ihrer wohnung ganz ehrlich caroline
ich finde du solltest aber aktiv werden
bisschen einkaufen und irgendwann wer
sich caroline ihren größten nageler
traum erfüllen zusammen mit fabrizio
will sie ein eigenes nagellack museum
eröffnet
was heißt sie will so gucken den raum
nagellacke aus der ganzen welt tunesien
japan überall weltweit 10.000 stück
ich würde sagen dass nagellack museum
wurde bereits eröffnet
ja das was man diesen kleinen video
schreibt mir die kommentare was ihr
davon haltet und schreibt vielleicht
auch mal rein was ihr sammeln würde
wonach ihr süchtig wert wenn ihr genug
geld hättet ihr kriegt hier ein für euch
vorgeschlagen das video hier oben könnt
ihr main kanal aber natürlich sehr
freuen ich bin der stelle raus bleibt
stabil
habt weiterhin 10.000 nagellacke zschau